hunter-gatherer societies you share with
a lot of people you go through your ups
and downs they help you you help them
there's a real feeling of closeness okay
you come to a marking Society and it's
much more productive okay so the
absolute level of welfare goes way up
but it creates this this deep insecurity
do these people really care about me or
not
my name is john tooby i'm a co-director
of the center for evolutionary
psychology at University of California
Santa Barbara with my wife and lifelong
collaborator leda cosmides when I was a
freshman majoring in physics I had been
thinking a lot about evolutionary
applications and making sense of the
world in that way and I thought well
I'll go check our what they're doing in
psychology and to my astonishment then
which is 1970 and it's I'm still
astonished 40 years later although
there's been some changes there was
almost no use of the really powerful
idea that the only force that organizes
any biological system functionally is
natural selection I thought well I know
as much as they do because they don't
know anything right before my sophomore
year I discovered that there was a whole
field of evolution and behavior
evolutionary biologists applying their
theories to understanding animal
behavior and I got very excited because
it promised to not just say how it is
that animals do what they do but why
they do what they do and why humans do
what they do what we thought was that
was missing from the early approaches to
sociobiology was this level of
description of what's the architecture
of the human mind what are the programs
that we all have by virtue of being
human beings and so a lot of our early
careers we spent trying to figure out
well what do we mean by that and how do
you study it and so forth and so we
spent a lot of years thinking about that
and working with colleagues on what are
the foundations of evolutionary
psychology initially people were
horrified at the idea of applying
evolutionary thinking to the human mind
the first paper I ever wrote much to my
surprise took many years to get into a
journal not because the results were
uninteresting but because the journals
were horrified at the idea that the
hypotheses were derived from an
evolutionary theory if I had had the
same hypothesis vibin playing pinball
and it just come to me as a hypothesis
that would have been okay but the idea
that as I always thought scientists were
supposed to that you had a larger theory
for which you derived
testable hypotheses and then you tested
them that was what was objectionable
when you know back in 1985 marks plug
talked about science progressing funeral
by funeral whereas it's not that people
who had one set of opinions get
convinced and changed their minds like
the ideal sometimes they do although
it's a rare and interesting and highly
valued but but much more commonly
younger people who don't have a stake
are the people who adopt it and they
grow up with a new way of thinking and
that's that's really happening
evolutionary psychology is an approach
to understanding the human mind in which
you really take seriously the idea that
our minds were shaped by natural
selection and that they were designed to
operate in an ancestral environment of
hunter-gatherer life it's a it's a
vanished way of life now but where we
lived in small social groups of you know
maybe 50 to 200 people many of whom were
close kin and and the idea is that we're
trying to understand what are the
reliably developing species-typical
programs that are that constitute human
nature we have a friend and mentor Roger
Shepard who's a one of the founders of
cognitive science and he said that
perception is externally driven
hallucination all sorts of things that
we think are matters of the external
world are in fact you know these matrix
programs playing in our heads and
structuring the world for us and there
really is of course an external world
and that corresponds sometimes to some
of these elements but but we're lost in
this video game that we mistake for
reality our experience in the visual
world is is highly constructed by
programs that we have no conscious
access to that's common you'll learn
that in any kind of psychology course
we're evolutionary psychology differs is
a notion that we have first of all that
you have many programs in your head not
just one big learning mechanism but many
different many different learning
mechanisms designed for learning about
different aspects of the world and and
that they they structure even our social
intuitions and our moral intuitions and
our intuitions about how to behave with
how to cooperate and how to behave with
other people
that's flies in the face of the main
approach to human mind for most of the
last century which is a standard social
science model model that we have a blank
slate mind and that all content in our
heads comes from experience from the
world the sort of new view with you know
the human mind is full of active
programs sifting information
spontaneously interacting making
decisions making decisions making
inferences about what's true finding
ways to be individual and discover ways
of being valuable to others in a highly
individual ways it's a much more
interesting and dynamic sort of 21st
century view of what it is to be a human
if you're a hunter-gatherer it's really
hard to get too much fat game animals
are really lean they're hard to get they
run away from you and if you don't have
a taste for fats you're not going to go
to all the trouble to be hunting at
sugar is the same way you're going to
get your sugar from from fruits mostly
fruit and sometimes honey and you just
can't get too much of it is a
hunter-gatherer now fast-forward to the
modern world we have a market economy
that produces immense amounts of food
from all parts of the world we have
access to two well fed animals that are
marbled with fat we have access to all
kinds of sugars and ice creams and so
forth there's a mismatch between
ancestral conditions in the modern
environment and so a taste for fats and
sugars it was very that's a result of
adaptations that were reproduction
promoting in the past is now causing
problems for us in the present I think
our hunter-gatherer ancestors plays a
role in how profoundly we misunderstand
the economic world we're not designed to
understand invisible hand processes at
all if somebody says I'll do this for
you but only if you do that for me
that's a sign of social distance for
humans and an explicit exchange okay you
with your friends that you say well of
course I'll do it you know if you they
invited you over for dinner at the end
you got up and you offered to pay them
that would be weird
and that would also be a sign that you
didn't really feel close to them
explicit exchange is a sign of social
distance that's what you do with people
that you don't know very well so think
about now in a market economy every time
I go to Starbucks and get a mocha I'm
engaging in explicit exchange every time
I do most things that I do in a market
economy they're explicit exchange every
time I do that I'm getting a signal of
social distance that these are not
people who care about my welfare that
they I am not uniquely valued the fact
that the natural world is very large is
zero-sum world permeates our thinking so
when we see wealth we think of it it was
taken away from somebody else and not
created where there was no wealth before
okay so it's it's very interesting to me
that you know we now
live in a world which is amazingly
wealthy in industrialized societies and
people have no appreciation about how
intricate and how labor-intensive and
how unlikely a set of arrangements those
are redistribution of societies and by a
large remain poor and societies which
allow people who don't have something to
create something create new wealth that
didn't exist before and so we've gone
from a world in which you know 99.99% of
people are for to a world in which
depending on your definition you know a
few percent in the West are poor
sometimes you have natural experiments
like the Berlin Wall we have West Berlin
in the East Berlin huge difference H
didn't stone between two philosophies to
social philosophies that really wasn't
that was a real experiment the idea of
socialism is harkening back to this
sharing level of people who care about
you but then it's it's delivery in a
mass society is that the people making
the decisions don't know about you don't
care about you and in fact there what
there are all the only thing they're
supposed to view as important is what
good are you to the social system and so
that has this that's why it always
sounds nice prospectively but turns into
a hell on earth when it's actually
implemented it's a problem that so many
story ins will write about all sorts of
things without thinking it's necessary
to understand economics and they make
all sorts of conclusions about economics
without people will think it's okay to
run for public office without having
ever taken any economics without having
any clue about how markets work it's
amazing shocking it
I'm not kidding it's it's shocking